what is the purpose of the miniseries
the purpose of the minisera is to give
you
a chance to be acquainted with some of
the main events
in the lifetime of the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
without having to watch uh voluminous
kind of series of online or reads
encyclopedic seerah books for example so
this is a brief
this is a brief kind of episode for a
beginner an introduction to muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and of course in the time that i'm going
to dedicate to this
i will not be doing justice to the life
of the of the rasulullah
however if someone wants an introduction
maybe this video will give them
pointers in certain directions and give
them a flavor of something of the
prophet muhammad
so let's start by asking a question
which arises in the field of apologetics
which is usually the question that
michael cook and others
have put forward in the 70s and 80s is
the revisionist question the historical
question did muhammad sallallahu alaihi
even exist in the first place and they
say that well we're over relying
you know on arabic sources and muslim
sources and therefore
the question of whether this man
muhammad sallallahu islam exists in the
first place
is something which needs to be answered
the straight answer is
we have a plethora of evidence in the
arabic as
they know the quran being one of the
strongest evidences by the way
which mentions muhammad by name four or
five times
and which is stated to the time where he
is meant to have existed
and of course the sahaba and the taber
in the companions and those who came
after them etc are also a testament to
this because they literally
witnessed his existence but the colonial
and racist or imperial
or orientalist historian might not be
necessarily satisfied with that because
they don't trust for some reason or
another
the arabic sources it has to be
something from the west
well there's no shortage of that either
uh second century
geographer ptolemy and we've got to be
because many ptolemies in the
historical record we're talking about
the second century geographer
he actually mentions yathriba which
we'll know as yethrib
and makaba or mecca he mentions this in
the second century
so the sites the holy sites of mecca and
yathrib
which would then become medina was
something that was referred to well
before the existence of the prophet
muhammad
and it's not just that for example john
fennick who is a 7th century
historian actually mentions muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam by name
and he is writing in the greek language
and he mentions him by name
not only that but he mentions that he is
an instructor and a guide
for the people and so these are just
some examples of uh histories
histories from other than the arabs but
this is just a taster
quite frankly because in many of the
wars like motta and tabok and others
there are actually
roman accounts of those particular wars
which took place between the arab people
whose leader was obviously muhammad
allah and
the romans for example so this really is
a pathetic interrogation
but it's important for us as muslims to
be able to defend ourselves from it
and for those non-muslims to be
convinced of
the evidence is not just from our
perspective but from
a triangulated perspective perspective
using the historical
critical method the hc m
now having said that now let's talk
about what context
was the arabian peninsula in the seventh
century
many of us will know the story of al-fil
the story of the
the elephant where before the prophet
muhammad
was born in fact there was
a delegation from abyssinia at the time
who attempted to
go into mecca and to destroy the kaaba
which is the black box for those who
don't know what that is where
muslims prayed to wards at that time
obviously was surrounded by 360 idols
and when they went and tried to do that
allah
god almighty this obviously is a sacred
history
but a recorded ticket history at that to
be fair he sent down
hijara he sent down these pelting stones
from the birds that literally dropped
them and the elephant
that came from the from the abyssinian
from abyssini at that time had to
disperse fleetingly
but this is something of the context we
should know something about
the culture not just the political
events as this probably would be
considered one
what is it what was the culture of the
arabs at the time well as you guys know
or at least maybe you should know that
in the seventh century the
there were two major uh powers you had
the sassanid empire which is the persian
empire
and you had the roman empire as well and
those two empires were the two
major empires as many of you definitely
would have known that
and the arabia the arabian peninsula was
actually lodged in the middle of those
two places
it didn't have well at least not at that
time no one had discovered natural
resources yet
oil or something like this it was a hot
desert climate just as it is now if you
go to saudi arabia especially in the
summer time
or anywhere in the arabian peninsula you
will feel the heat
you will feel the heat and so it was a
very hot place
humid hot it was a tribal society so
there wasn't necessarily like a
government or federal system or some
kind of top-down
system like this unlike obviously the
uh rigorous kind of organizational
structure that existed in both
assassinate
and the roman empires and
you had you had a warrior culture
quite frankly because obviously if
you're tribes the thing that
you're going to need to do a lot of is
fight and fight with other tribes
and in fact interestingly enough um
there are some things called the
actually these very famous poetries that
existed before the time of the prophet
muhammad
lived and these are called literally
means the hand ones because
it was said that they were hanged on the
cab on that like they literally hang on
the black box the cabba
and um obviously i don't know if it was
black then maybe
they put another color on it but now we
know it as black obviously if you look
at the pictures
but the point is it was said to be the
case but some historians
differ with this this naming of this
coinage that is in fact uh
that should be called the malacca to
anything like that as some refer to them
as the habit because it was written in
golden income
and this is something which we don't
need to go too deeply into but what i
want to
give you a taster of is something that
one of the
uh poets the warrior poets called
antarabinshid
he was an ethiopian man who came from a
slave lineage
who was a warrior and i want to give you
a flavor of the kind of thing that he
would
um write poems about so let's listen to
this very interesting he says this
he says
either
he says let your swords judge in the
face of the enemy
let your swords judge in the face of the
enemy
and he says and when you enter upon a
land disgraced
then leave that land in other words
don't don't face and accept humiliation
you can see now what kind of culture
this is a war
a proud culture a warrior culture
and when you see an oppressor he says
we're either buliith
with an oppressor listen to this
be more of an oppressor
and you you see the one an ignorant one
if you see an ignorant one if you see
someone who wants to get rude basically
you want to put it in street language
you want to get rude then get rude more
be more ignorant with them and you can
see
you know you can see subhanallah the
warrior the spirit
the fight the pride the bravery the
courage
the gallantness of those people this
particular
actually uh anthony vince i'm mentioning
him because just to give you a taster
of the culture that existed before he
actually had a love of his life her name
was abla
and in fact one of his most famous
poetries was
he's speaking to the in the house of
ablah
now because of his race and this shows
you what islam did in terms of
transformative effect
because he was black and habla was an
arab okay
he couldn't be with habla so she was
like the forbidden love
you see what i mean she was like the
forbidden love so look imagine this this
guy he's a soldier he's a warrior
he's going out this way he's going right
he's fighting everyone with the swords
people when they see him they just flee
because they they know
when this guy throws the bow uh sorry
the arrow when they just see his bow
they want to run away because they know
he's got that
he's got that precision and he's got
that sword strength
but even him he's outside of the dar of
the house of ablah
who he would he want to be with
and he's saying he's saying oh how he's
speaking to the house
look at that personification and it
shows you the imagery and the
personification and the richness
of of language that these guys had at
that time
oh house of habla yeah
he says he's speaking to it speak back
to me basically he's saying to her
and then he says something and wake up
in the morning
of of of of habla and
come to me and and so basically he's
talking to the house
because it's sentimental because
abdullah used to live there but he
couldn't be with
her now obviously we're not going to get
there yet but just bear that in mind
that we
this was a racist society someone like
antara bin shiddad couldn't get
married to he's black he could not get
married yeah to someone who's another
race
but all of that changes as we know bill
ibn
he became the highest level um
caller to prayer yeah for the muslims
and not only that but he he also got
married to an arabs
hellebent alf for your information so
that shows you a transformative effect
of the islamic kind of morality
on the arab society already it was a
racist society it was an
unequal society and in terms of
sexuality it was loose
in terms of sexuality it's very loose
some people think that okay we're living
in a very sexually loose society now
it's true
but then before islam was quite loose as
well because
you had these these kind of prostitute
houses
okay brothels call them that if you want
brothels and the woman will be obviously
having intercourse with lots of men
she'll be having intercourse with this
man and this one and
when she gets pregnant because obviously
at that time they didn't have
contraception or maybe they did
understand cortisone interruptus but not
always
will it work she'll bring all the men
that she had intercourse with
and she'll say you're the father whoever
she likes the most she'll point them and
say you're the father
and obviously when islam came in
addition to destroying racist
elements it also destroyed this idea of
not knowing where your lineage is in
fact one of the five
things that islam came to protect was
lineage so this kind of practice was
put to an end and people talk about
polygamy but there was an unrestricted
polygamy at that time
you know and women were doing it as well
like everyone was everyone was wild
and so that gives you a kind of like
understanding i've kind of already just
alluded to this already but
the fact that was 160 360 idols around
the kaaba
so it was a paganistic culture um
there were remnants probably of
christianity and judaism judaism in
medina when we get there but
christianity there were some people that
uh kind of understood what christianity
was and
but really the arabs were pagan they
were pagan
okay and they believed in idols and they
worshipped their idols and in fact it
was their source of income
which is why when the prophet came with
tahit the idea of monotheism
they saw it as such a threat because it
wasn't just a theological threat it was
an economic threat as well
um so we spoke about that we're talking
about poetry
and we spoke about some of the context
that desert environment
um and how marriage was and stuff like
that
we're going to be talking now about the
prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam himself
so look the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
he was from a a particular tribe called
banu hashim which was a sub-tribe
of quraish okay so he was from it was
which was
a very prestigious if not the most
prestigious tribe and of course the
lineage of that
goes back to ismail uh ismail ishmael
who is obviously one of the two
two sons that we know of of abraham or
that i mentioned in the scriptures of
abraham
ibrahim and
so the lineage goes back to to abraham
as
if you don't know already okay the jews
and the arabs are actually cousins from
that perspective
especially what we see now of palestine
israel it's a bit ironic when you think
about it like that right
and it's usually the narcissism of small
difference when people are closer
together
sometimes the conflict becomes even more
pronounced
but he was from that lineage he was the
he was from the lineage of abraham
and he was from the lineage in
particular of ismail
and what happened was when he was born
in fact the
sacred history tells us that his mother
amina
she basically had light emanate from her
from her when she went when he when he
was born and
this is a miracle one of many different
miracles that took place at the time of
the prophet muhammed when he was younger
his heart was taken out and washed
literally he had an
angelic open heart surgery that would
spiritualize and to cleanse and purify
his heart
the center of spiritual revelation
for what would happen next to him and
the kids saw that and that's written on
our spiritual
or sacred histories when he got a bit
older he started obviously working now
and he was a man with a meditative
temperament okay he was
he was known in the community as
known a somebody who was trustworthy
truthful and trustworthy
that's why some people would go to him
and basically they would leave their
stuff with him
like for example if they're going
somewhere and they want to leave someone
like a safety deposit box
they'd go to his house and say can you
take care of this one and he was known
for that
okay and this shows you already the
trust that he had in the community
by the way someone may object from an
apologetics perspective and say
well that's just you saying that
obviously you will say that you're a
muslim and you're biased
but what we'll say in response to that
is being polemical here
well actually this was used as one of
the arguments in the quran and in the
sunnah
and had it held no currency it wouldn't
have been used or at least it would have
been refuted
in other words the things that the
opponents of the prophet muhammed
say like he's a magician
that he is majnun he's insane
that he is possessed by the devil uh
that he
all those things that they they make
about him or the fabrications that they
make about him
not one of them is not that he's not
trustworthy he's a liar bear that in
mind that no one actually made that and
we have by the way
so many reports which fulfill the
principle of embarrassment meaning
that even some of the orientalists admit
these reports show us that the histories
are actually authentic it's one of the
principles of history
the principle of embarrassment probably
chief most of which is the satanic
verses
the fact that that made it into the the
hadith literature in the first place
shows that the one really and we'll talk
about this by the way in its own
we'll give it its own treatment when we
do sapient thoughts on sapient institute
website
youtube page but the point is is that
things were just recorded things were
just recorded and that's why even things
which are weak or inauthentic
or fabricated make it into the tradition
and that's why there is a process of
cleaning up
the tradition that has taken place
through el mor-rijal or the idea of
tadil looking at who said what and
seeing if they have a bias or not and
this was a critical method employed
by the first people in islam but that's
another lecture for another time let's
continue now and talk about the prophet
muhammad sallallahu alaihi sallam so the
prophet muhammad he was known as
he was known as the truthful and the
trustworthy one people would leave this
stuff in his house
there were many incidents that he showed
superior wisdom
like for example the kaaba had been
destroyed at one time and they were
reassembling it
and the last brick they wanted to put
back in place in order to reassemble it
and every tribe wanted to put the brick
and they were saying let me put the
brick and whatever
so then they said let the next man that
comes through here he be the
arbitrator of our dispute and it was
none other than the prophet muhammad
obviously at that time he had not
received revelation
and he said look i got an idea he said
what's the idea he said look put the
brick in the middle here
everyone lived it lift it like so all of
you get the honor of lifting the brick
and putting it back in its place and i'm
gonna push it in its place
so look at that it's an extremely wise
kind of solution to the problem that
they had
so he was known for that kind of thing
and he was a trader in fact he was also
shepherd
you know the prophet muhammad was the
custom in arabian times he was sent
to the desert basically because it helps
with articulation
you get tough you get strong and by the
way this is a lesson for us because we
are
too luxurious here in the west like
especially if we're from a certain
country whether it's
you know a middle eastern country an
african country an asian country ever
we should go back and kind of see the
roughness in that country because we get
too complacent
and ungrateful so the arabs knew that
very well and they used to put their
kids in this basically in the desert
to be raised with these people and
they would pick up the language in a
better way they would have a better
kind of connection with nature and they
would come out rougher and tougher in
other words they had the warrior spirit
the prophet saw he went through that as
well and he became a shepherd at one
point
and what's really interesting about all
the prophets as a hadith that says that
all the prophets
were practically all of them practically
shepherds and if you think about
the idea of a shepherd the shepherd
actually guides the flock and that's
what a prophet does
so this is a kind of tamheed if you like
or it's a kind of preparation
for all of the prophets to the guidance
to the enterprise of guiding the people
what's really interesting is if you find
um
goats and stuff like that their eyes are
actually by the side of their face not
in front of their face
so they can't really see in front that
well so they need a shepherd in order to
show them the straight path
and so it's physically a very
appropriate thing to have a shepherd
that would literally show them the
straight path and obviously the prophet
sallam
and what would come would show the
people the spiritual straight path
and and let them know and guide them and
instruct them so after being a shepherd
he started working as a trader
which basically shows as well that you
need to get out there and do work
because the prophet muhammed was not
on at home doing job seekers allowance
or the or
he wasn't on the dole he wasn't
depending on other people to maintain
him like that
he was out there working hard and in
fact his his boss was
khadijah a woman who was shrewd
extremely intelligent woman you know
extremely noble woman who had kids
before from her previous
marriage you know she had been married
before and so on
and she had been a woman that the
prophet muhammad really admired
so obviously he'd he'd pack things he'd
go into the caravan they'd do things
and she looked at him she said this man
is amazing
this man is amazing he's trustworthy you
know
he's he's always doing exactly what is
expected of him he does more
he gets the business done he's
proficient he is if you want to put it
in a contemporary language
he is professional he is a professional
which shows us already that look
at work we need to be professional you
know
it's that is not even people say let's
do that with our actions
that is a sufficient but not necessary
requirement it's unnecessary but not
sufficient
dawah is done by calling people to tell
hate but you need to
at the base level show a level of
professionalism at work with your
colleagues
with your friends because that's where
it all starts with your personal
reputation
and the prophet had the best reputation
he had the best reputation
and no one really no one said anything
about him being honest
trustworthy all of those things and so
his wife hadija was always there for him
she would become his wife obviously at
this time she wasn't his wife here so
this woman khadija who was
who was his boss at this time she went
to one of her
kind of workers and she's nafisa she
said to you know do you think that a
prophet
or do you think that muhammad at that
time he wasn't the prophet right
and she said would you think that he
would be interested in someone like me
she didn't believe it like and then
ephesus went to muhammad sallallahu
alaihi salaam and she said do you think
that you'd be interested
he was like the same he's like you know
i don't think so you know why
humble like masha'allah you know and
and then he went to basically her uncle
and long story short they got married
and he was 25 and some reports say that
she was 28 or 29 some other reports they
said she was 40.
she was older than him full stop okay
she was older than him full stop
and she they still did business together
they still worked
you know it was still a very functional
marriage and he
he he always retreated now to the to the
cave
and this is called and if you go to
saudi arabia you can
you can see this place it's like it's a
small nice enclave like a small cave you
have to go up it's actually quite a long
thing to get up there
and he would just sit there and think
about god and he would think about
like purpose of life he had that as we
said a meditative temperament
which shows you really the power of
seclusion
just being by yourself sometimes like
the the age that we live in is too much
hustle and bustle in the cosmopolitan
world that we live in
to retreat sometimes by yourself even if
you're in a car driving or something
just by yourself and think to yourself
you know
this is what i need to get done you can
clear your thoughts have clarity of mind
that's what he was trying to achieve
and he he wanted to worship god so he'd
do this regularly he'd go to the cave
you know his wife was very supportive
his wife was very
like extremely supportive and he went to
the cave one day
and he was doing the same routine that
he's used to
which shows you the power of routine and
all of a sudden he was grabbed he was he
was
something held on to him and seized him
and he was shocked by it and it's and
whatever that thing was
said said read recite
and he said i can't read it's
not something i can do because he was
illiterate sallallahu
because it was the society actually most
people in that society couldn't read and
write was an oral culture
so most poetry was done orally rather
than through the pen
one more time read recite because means
read but it also means recite
he goes i can't read this is what's this
like you know
shock a feeling of shock
and you can imagine now just him in the
cave feeling like that and feeling
constrained feeling constrained straight
jacketed by this experience
and and shocked because this is known
this is no joke of an experience right
now
and then finally
read in thy name of your lord who
created
created the human being from a clot
yes and read and your lord is the most
generous
the one who taught with the pen he's the
one who taught
with the pen after that
he was shocked and then you he was it
was released
that feeling that straight jacketed
he could finally exhale now he could
finally exhale now this was a
shocking experience and he looked up
into the
horizon and he saw something an angelic
creature with
huge wings like imagine seeing a huge
tree in front of you
that blocks the entire
your entire vision it shades everything
that's in front of it
he went back home and he said to his
wife he said seven million
he said just cover me up cover me up
look how
look how honest this report is
look how human this report is
look how it reveals the the very
normal and natural insecurities of human
being
of vulnerability of vulnerability to
things which are unpredictable
to things which create anxiousness
this is reported that he said
he said cover me up
and then khadija walla when you hear the
stuff that she says and reaffirming
words
you know why she's the best she's the
best wife that the prophet muhammed ever
had no doubt about it
no doubt about her she was like no allah
wouldn't punish you
and she mentioned some of his good
traits that he feeds the poor charity
that he does
that is good to the orphan the prophet
himself was an orphan
don't forget that he was an orphan and
when you remember
when we say that the prophet muhammad
was an orphan
you think to yourself when these people
talk about him in the negative way
do they even know that he was an orphan
that he lived this underprivileged
socio-economic upbringing he was an
orphan
and and and hadith going back to the
point
was was convincing him look don't worry
allah is not punished not punishment
and the prophet muhammad saw allah he
was still shivering and
shocked being in the
and so what khadijah said she had a
cousin
no philbin was sorry yeah
he was a christian now that was one of
the few christians that lived in mecca
so they went to him and
they said they said to him like what's
going on right now
so he basically because obviously his
access to the new testament or
biblical information or whatever you
want to call it christianity he had
access to
the christian tradition to some extent
whatever form it took in arabia
at that time and bear in mind the the
bible was not translated in arabic at
that time
it was not translated the old testament
or the new testament but he this was
full and and and he said look this is
this is you know uh the angel that comes
to all of the prophets
and he started giving warnings to the
prophet muhammad saying look
you are gonna face persecution basically
to put it in a long story short and i'm
paraphrasing he said basically you're
gonna
because this this kind of thing didn't
happen to anybody except that they faced
persecution
and resistance
and that's exactly what he faced just a
quick correction i
when i was mentioning the prophet mum's
name it was not
amina it's by the way just a quick
correction now we're at the point
in the seerah where the prophet muhammad
had that first revelation and how
intense
how intense was that first revelation
imagine once again just imagine with me
that you are seized and and feel like
you're being straight jacketed by some
force that you can't even see
and you are told to read and recite and
you can't read and rest you don't know
what's going on you go back to your wife
and she and he's shaking covering me up
i don't know what's happening
i don't know what's going on right now
she takes him to work
the cousin of khadijah
and he's telling him he's telling her
this is what's going to happen it's
going to be
there's going to be resistance there's
going to be persecution there's going to
be whatever
and so subhanallah what happens after
that is
she's obviously reaffirming it for him
and saying that look you're a good man
trust me this is not punishment from god
but he feels insecure he feels like
and this is this is the mark of a
sincere person
where they always feel like that there's
something wrong with them even if
even if they're perfect even if they're
sinless
they always feel like there's more to be
done they're always yearning for
perfection
they're always blaming themselves it was
finding a reason
to improve a mark of a successful person
is someone who finds a reason to improve
and so the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
he was by himself and for months and
months now
he was he was not getting that
revelation and as
as worrying and scary and traumatic as
it was
he missed it he felt like maybe
god almighty is upset with something
that i did something i fought something
like
he started getting really bad anxiety
like extremely bad anxiety acute
anxiety
and months would go by and
there's a famous report in bukhari which
says that oh he has suicidal thoughts by
the way that report is moderate
it's not something the prophet saw ever
said himself
who narrates this hadith that's his
commentary of it so he had
very very very deep
level deep-seated anxieties there's no
evidence to suggest that he had these
suicidal thoughts however
but it shows you the length or i mean
the extent
of his cousin of his sadness and sorrow
and just for
interestingly nowadays a lot of people
suffer from mental health
disorders like depression
chronic depression anxiety and so on
and they think by the way a lot of
people think
that going through stages of your life
where you're feeling anxious and
depressed
that that diminishes your status as a
muslim person
that's false that's absolutely false
it doesn't diminish your status as a
muslim person in fact we have
things in the quran of mary maria
when she was saying i wish i was dead
basically
well i wish i was forgotten even i was
when she was giving birth the pain that
that
and the embarrassment that she felt when
she was giving birth to jesus
and we have also in this in the quran
jacob
in in surah yusuf chapter 12 of the
quran
where he literally had so much
hosun like deep seated anxiety
because he lost his son that he went
blind
like let me ask you a question and just
think about this for a second now
what if he went to a psychiatrist or a
psychologist or someone who was
trained in the field and he explained or
if someone say
it does that and they explain that they
have gone blind because of their anxiety
i'm sure they would prescribe
antidepressants and say look you've got
a high level
you know you've got high level anxiety
and depression and these kinds of things
but he said
beautiful patience for so
what we don't offer and i'm being very
straightforward here
what muslims don't offer is
that you're not going to have anxiety in
your life you're not going to have
depression you're not going to have to
let you're not going to have tests
do people think that they're just going
to be left like that and say that we
believe
and they were not going to be tested
that we have certainly tested those who
have come before them
so allah will know in other words
distinguish between those who are
truthful and sincere
and those ones who are liars in other
words insincere
and allah he mentions in the quran
and this came as people were becoming
muslim at this verse by the way
with something of naksmen
deficiencies and health you'll be more
scared
anxiousness jew hunger
deficiencies in wealth etc these are
tests
what islam offers to people is not a
magic pill to depression and anxiety
such a magic pill does not exist
let me just be very clear about that
such that even the prophet is not immune
from anxiety
and not him just not just him other
prophets that came before him
he's not immune from anxiety this is one
of many different times in the life of
the prophet we're going to find that he
went through
at least what would be referred to in
the psychological literature as
tr transitory sadness
because i think that they differentiate
between transitory sadness and
depression
through the chronicle nature of the
of the episode or lack thereof there's
some of them say six months if it's more
than six months
interestingly enough this is six months
right it was more than six months
subhanallah they say it was more than
six months it's not
chronic depression they call it
transitory sadness but six months later
now
in a useful segway the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he revealed the next uh surah the quran
or the next ayat of the quran in chapter
these verses in chapter number 74 oh you
who is wrapped in garments
get up and warn the people or rebecca
and go ahead and glorify your lord
now imagine do you know like let me tell
you something maybe we can make this
work for you a little bit
you might have you might have a love
life interest in your life you might
have someone you like
or something you love and it doesn't
necessarily have to be a spouse it
doesn't necessarily have to be
um a part no it's tough for allah if
you're not muslim watching this but you
know
there are no muslims watching this a
partner right a girlfriend or a
boyfriend
hopefully you'll come to the truth and
you won't have to live like that anymore
but let's just say you have that
and you see when your phone gets like
starts vibrating and like it starts
flashing or something like that
thinking oh who is it and you you're you
know
you're anxious you want to know who it
is you want to know if it's that person
it could even be
it can even be someone that's not
romantic in their romantic setting
it can be a platonic relationship like
your mum or your dad like
someone that you love and that you want
to see if they're okay or your son or
your daughter
love interest in your life when they
call you or
especially when there has been a hiatus
and there's been a lack of interactivity
between you and that person
you feel like very very like even more
enthused when it comes to retrieving the
information that they have
we have this we have this kind of
experience now imagine imagine
the prophet muhammed now after six
months of hiatus there's no
revolut it's a revelatory hiatus he gets
this
phone call if you want to call it that
angelic phone call
but who's calling allah subhanahu ta'ala
he's the one who's calling imagine the
happiness
imagine the euphoria use this word
now honestly this especially if someone
has had like a spell
of anxiousness and maybe depression
let's use the word depression
he's had that at least transit through
sadness deep seated
sadness and then allah
like rings your phone and then starts
speaking to you that same voice that you
heard the angel gabriel
the same angel that came to all the
prophets that came before him well this
it's a different story now it's a
different story now
and it's giving them instructions now
tell me
how much more motivated would the
prophet have been
because of this hiatus because he's
blaming himself this whole time feeling
insecure
to do the things that are mentioned even
though they could put his life at risk
and this is a very important point
this is extremely important for anyone
who wants to doubt the messenger
prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi why
would a man who's living
as a minority with a
seemingly new religion especially in the
cultural
kind of environment at that time put
himself in a position
where he's now going to be boycotted his
people are going to be persecuted et
cetera
in fact when
this these verses came down other verses
came down like when the uh ashirataka
karabin and warn your close family the
ashira
comes from the arabic word literally
meaning 10
or those extended family members go and
go and
go and warn your extended family members
and the first muslims were people like
obviously khadijah
she believed him straight away she knows
his track record she's lived with the
man
she married him because he was a so the
truthful and trustworthy one
she believed ali abby talib he believed
he believed abu bakr
said and he was named as-siddiq because
of how much he believes
bilal others there were many people that
became muslim
and they were at the lower echelons of
society at that time
and because of it they were boycotted
they were attacked
they were physically injured you know
very famously was they put boulders on
him
they killed somaya a woman who her son
was amar
ibn yasser he had to see his mom they
would have killed it like this was
serious stuff
if you if you don't even have any
strength you're living in
in mecca and you're seeing all this
happen it takes only a sincere person
i cannot imagine that someone will be
doing this in their instance how think
about that for a second just try and let
that settle in your brain let it ferment
in your mind
why would someone who is insincere
endure
years of persecution boycott
pain disaster years of that
seeing people his fa his his close
people being killed
then there was an economic boycott these
guys were getting so hungry that they
were eating leaves
they're getting hungry it's not if it
was for worldly reasons they actually
offered him
they offered him all the worldly
pursuits and he refused it
they tried to compromise with him so
many times that the quran actually had
verses revealed on the matter
disbelievers i'm not going to believe
what you believe and you're not going to
believe what i believe
and yo and so on you have your religion
and i have mine
for you they wish that you can
compromise so
that you can compromise with them and
they would compromise with you the quran
says that in chapter 67 verse 3
so the the point of the matter is they
wanted to compromise but the prophet had
no compromise with tawhid
that's why this is the pure and
respectable monotheism
the tawheed the believing and
worshipping the creator god
that created the universe without
partners or associates we don't believe
god is a man
or human being we don't believe god is a
statue or is
in his in a statue
we don't believe something can supervene
on the nature of god
we believe in the creator god the all
wise the all-powerful the most merciful
the creator of the universe the
sustainer of the universe
yes and that is the one god that we
worship and that was the
that was the uncompromising message for
13 years you know what i say 13 years
when i say 13 years you guys might think
okay what 13 years
13 years that is a considerable chunk
out of someone's adult life
13 years is no joke with all due respect
for someone to be enduring all of that
we trivialize it
we say oh you know 13 years no 13 years
going through boycott
persecution the prophet went to
prostrate
and some people they put in the bowels
of the animal on him and his daughter
had to watch that like this is living
a difficult difficult difficult life
for what for the for allah is not he was
definitely not going to compromise with
these people
on that the message of the quran
remained resilient
and the prophetic mission remained
resilient as well
and what happened was he had an uncle
called abu talib
and this uncle was not a muslim but he
was very much
you could say sympathetic to the prophet
muhammad and because he had that
connection
it basically prevented them from killing
him and what happened was when there was
there was a year
where his uncle and his wife both died
like imagine this the love of his life
khadija
who who was there for him like you know
he came back from the
she was there for him before that she
was supporting him with her money like
she was a businesswoman
he was they were working to used to be
and and now
this person who was at his side and he
had daughters of her in fact
all of his daughters were from with her
all of his daughters
including fatima were with
and now she dies and
abu talib the man he actually he loved
he had a connection with him
and so much so that he why he wanted him
to become muslim allah revealed
you're not going to guide who you want
but allah guides whom he wills
and both of them died in the same year
and this was this was the year that was
referred to as
the year of grief
once again going back to mental health
it shows you it shows you that we are
all human and we are susceptible to
these things
the extraneous variables in our life and
our humanly existence
will have an effect on our mood
whether you like it or not and it had an
effect on if it had an effect on
muhammad al-assam's mood
do not think it will not have any effect
on your mood do not think you should be
or you're entitled to be
immune from this you're not entitled to
be immune from anxiety all your life
the purpose of life is not for you to
feel completely happy all the time
the purpose of life is to worship allah
despite what you think we feel
that's the purpose of life so what
happened is that a prophet muhammad
sallam started to gain support
and people started to become muslim in
small pockets
and so he started speaking to people
from this town
called the ethrip
and there were two main tribes there
also
and those two major tribes basically he
did dollar to them he brought them
he told them islam he didn't have any
monetary thing to offer them by the way
and this is extremely important point
because it's going to signal that
how the prophet became a leader in
medina he became a leader in what would
become
named medina not through demolition or
violence
he became a leader through popular
opinion
think about that for a second he didn't
become a leader because there was
someone before him
and this differentiates him from all of
the others by the way the kings of the
roman empire
no these guys were inherent for the most
part they inherited a monarchy right
the prophet became a leader by pop
backed by popular opinion
he did not have anything monetary to
offer these people at all
when he left now for the hijrah he left
with abu bakr
obviously his companion and stuff and
they had they had a warrant for his
arrest and his death
okay and
when they had a warrant for his arrest
they
tried to kill him in fact there's a
there's a there's a famous story of
salah
malik of a man who tried to catch him
and as he approached the legs of this
horse of this guy
it sank into the into the sand
and the prophet and he came to the
prophet knowing now he's a prophet
because
how could this happen and he became
muslim this
and malik and this hadith is in bukhari
and you will find that actually
he even predicted that he will be
wearing the bracelets
of kisrah of the assassinate king and at
the time of umar just to skip away
you know he actually this prophecy was
in fact actualized but the point is
they made it they made a break for it
and they went they went to
from mecca to medina before that
obviously and
i'm skipping a lot of stuff here for
example the emigration of a lot of the
muslims to abyssinia
okay and we could talk about that and
there were two such occasions
but the reason why i'm not mentioning it
directly is because it will descope
and it will make this too long right but
there was another when the prophet
sallam he sent a lot of the people that
have been persecuted to abyssinia
because there was a just king there
called najashi or
nagas as they call him right but before
that now they they had
moved towards medina and the austin
hazrat who had already accepted the
prophet
and his terms and there were two such
baja's pledge of allegiance
they welcomed him when he came and he
came there and it was it was kind of
like a celebratory experience
and now we mark and with 13 years we
just brushed through it maybe
an hour or whatever has been we're 13
years by and we have seen
the whole meccan period come to a close
now subhanallah the question of allah
when does it take place so the scholars
have differed so i'm not going to tell
you the difference opinion but
there was also an incident where the
prophet muhammed
where he went from from and this is why
jerusalem is very very
important to us muslims he went from and
this is we believe a miracle
he went from medina all the way to
jerusalem on this animal called al-buraq
now some i've seen some new atheists and
others they make a mockery of this i say
what are you talking about
how can you say that the prophet what
animal is this we want to know
what kind of animals is wait a minute
why is this uh impossible to believe on
what basis is this
very difficult to believe that he went
from mecca to medina
with this animal now we have planes that
do the job
we have rockets that go up as well you
think you as a human being can create
these technological things
and that allah cannot make an animal
that can do something better than your
machines this is the delusion and the
self
aggregation of the new atheists and in
fact if you if you take some of their
arguments
i actually had wondered conversation
just on the point of and they said
one conversation with an atheist once
and he believed in the multiverse
i said you know if you believe in the
multiverse and he said infinite amount
of universes
so if you believe in a multiverse of
infinite amount of universes that means
that all possibilities will actualize
including there's a man called muhammad
going on the borac
because that is a possibility it might
not be and he didn't realize this line
of argumentation
and it kind of stunned him and the point
is that even on other world views this
is not inconceivable so long as there's
a god out there
that can do all things which are
possible this is a possible thing it's
not an impossible thing it's not like a
square circle
and so we say that the prophet muhammad
was taken from
medina to jerusalem and he prayed there
and he led the prophets in prayer and
then he went up to the heavens
all seven of them and he spoke to allah
and that is when
the five prayers were revealed in this
spiritual
voyage and adventure so now when we pray
we have an outer
body experience we have a spiritual
experience where we're literally
ascending
maybe not physically as the prophet but
definitely spiritually
and that's why when we start praying we
say allahu akbar and we literally
mean that allah is greater than because
that's what the translation of that word
is
anything else we may be doing we are
transcending the worldly existence and
moving into a spiritual domain
which is completely above and beyond
our menial activities that we do on a
daily basis the prayer is never a waste
of time and it's the center of the
islamic experience
five times a day it anchors our belief
system and it gives us a sense of
stability and tranquility and serenity
and spiritual guidance that cannot be
afforded in any other exercise that
anyone can do
the prayer and that is when the prophet
sallam had this
amazing and miraculous interaction with
some of the previous prophets
chief most of which probably to be
remembered is moses who reduced the size
of the prayer from 50 to 5.
after a kind of transactional discussion
or interaction between the prophet
muhammed
and allah himself the creator of the
universe and yes of course allah can
facilitate such interaction
so when he came back some people
actually couldn't believe this because
empiricism was strong even then right
and so people couldn't believe this
they went to uh abraham and he said
very famously he said that if he said it
that this happened
they said to him you believe that he
actually went to jerusalem and they went
up to the sky and whatever
abu bakr and this is the reason why he
was referred to as a siddique if he said
it then it happened
and this is the attitude of a true
believer
when you see a quranic verse you see a
hadith which is authentic
you say if this is the verse then i
believe it
if someone brings that hadith that you
don't know and is
maybe inauthentic or you don't know if
it's authentic or not
and you want to be safe and protect
yourself say if it's authentic i accept
it
but nowadays it's a matter of
interpretation but the point being is
this
that incident took place
the muslims now had a polity and this
was the polity of medina
and obviously the quran she's those
pagan arabs that had been
the perpetuators or the perpetrators i
should say the perpetrators of the
boycott and
of the persecution this riled them up
and
aggravated them angered them
and so they wanted to fight the muslims
and what would become
probably the most famous battle of all
the battles that the prophet muhammad
took part in and let me just say
something about the prophet's battles
that he took part in all of them he
shared the risk
with his fellow comrades he didn't just
aloofy
say to his people go and fight and i'll
sit here in my
white house smoking a pipe somewhere he
went out with the people that fought
with him
he was a man even though he was in his
50s he would go out and fight as well
in the front line with the sword and
some people use this against the prophet
as if it is an argument against islam
if anything this is an argument for
islam why would a man risk his own life
fighting on the battlefield on the front
line if he is indeed
insincere to his cause knowing full well
that the risk
is death think about it yeah i mean
a lot of these people they're putting
the prophet muhammad as if he was some
kind of materialistic man
so 13 years of boycott and when he goes
to medina it's battle after battle after
battle
and uh he has to protect himself and
defend his people
so i don't see how that works and at
this time by the way
obviously khadijah had died he married a
woman called saudi zama
who was another elderly woman people
don't realize she was older than him
and she had her own kids and the prophet
married her so if he was a womanizer
this is another thing that comes to mind
why is he marrying people that are older
than him with kids why is he always
doing that
the third wife he had was
she was the one famously in the hadith
where she had a young age and so on
the hadith of nine years old and
whatever and at that time it was not
something that the people that
had any issues with people were getting
married at that time or all along
and we have another videos on this you
can put my name on youtube
and the marriage of aisha and stuff like
that if you want more information about
why at that age and so on but the point
is his marriage started to happen and a
lot of the marriages started to become
political in nature in the sense that
he would get married to women because he
wanted to create a
polity which was which was unified
and we'll come to examples of that in
what follows but aisha was the daughter
of abu bakr
as-siddiq so he was creating stronger
bonds between himself and the companions
and at this time so he's now in medina
creating his polity and the battle of
badr
takes place where there's only 313
of these muslims and they overpower and
defeat
in an amazing show of military strength
and wit those pagan arabs and it was
seen as something which really
established him as a force
in that area it totally established him
as a force in that area
and in fact this was predicted in the
quran
where allah says
that they're actually going to be
defeated and they're going to run away
that verse came before but that took
place and it was a prediction of them
running away and they did run away and
they lost
and this is another example of when the
quran makes predictions and it comes out
to be true
and so now after this the polity of
islam has been
established after this particular war
for those who say that the sacred
history sounds too good to be true
there was what some referred to as a
defeat and a setback with uh
where the prophet almost died himself
his teeth came out he was
injured and this shows you that he was
sharing that risk
that military risk
and after and after there was another
war there was war after war
there was war after war and i'm skipping
a lot here but let's say azap
so we're going to talk about before we
do so i think it's extremely important
to realize that when the prophet
muhammed came to medina
obviously it was called the ether and
then it the name changed to medina which
literally means in arabic
the city and medina
or the city of the prophet in the
abbreviated format would be
just the city of medina that's what it's
called medina now
when he got there he actually drafted a
what you would call a constitution in
fact this book here which i think is a
good read
for someone who wants to have an
introduction you know the english
language to the seerah gives us a bit of
a
kind of elaboration of what kind of
thing existed in this
and he he mentions obviously
in the treaty he mentions ibn hashem as
the reference but we also know that
ibn shah bazori had the ketab called
mahazi which is also a reference as well
but this
is an important treaty because it shows
that the intention was not
um to try and eradicate all the
pluralism that existed in the in medina
all that the intention was the
uniformity to try and bring everyone
force everyone to become a muslim this
is indeed
an insidious and it is a malignant
and it is a deceptive it is a crooked
lie
a monstrous falsehood that has been held
against the islamic tradition and
something which has no basis
in any of the primary source material
let's take a look at this treaty just to
give you a taster of what existed in the
treaty
the jews of banyalf are one community
with the believers it says
the jews will profess their religion and
the muslims theirs
because the quran even mentions this i
mean for women
for whoever wants to can believe and
whoever wants to can disbelieve
in chapter 18 you have your religion we
have ours we've already stated this
in the in the events that took place
before
the quran mentions in there's no
compulsion
in religion and here you have it now
enshrined
in a document in a treaty in a
constitution
which you could say existed that
facilitated the atmosphere
for people that were not muslim the
second point is jews shall be
responsible for their expenditure and
the muslims for theirs
seems very fair it doesn't seem like
there's any kind of domination going on
here some kind of
oppression no it says if attacked by a
third party it shall come to the help of
the other
seems like it's a civil society being
formed here in this new polity of medina
four each party shall hold counsel with
the other mutual relations shall be
founded on righteousness
sin is totally excluded so once again is
setting the expectation the moral
bar is set this is a moral society we're
not going to try and transgress one
against one another
in sin uh and listen to this neither
shall
uh commit sins to the prejudice of the
other
very straightforward the jews shall
contribute to the cost of war so long as
they are
to fight along the believers
some people say well look at the jizya
the discriminatory attacks
the jizya according to the earliest
authorities was less than
zakat it was less than the zakat
why is it discriminatory tax who is it
discriminatory towards the muslims
because the zakat is 2.5 percent of the
male and they have the cattle fit on
this
why is this why is the jews are so
discriminatory when it's less
when it is less in terms of an
expenditure for the for the population
of
non-muslims is it just because it has a
different name
yeah of course that's a different name
because there's a cat has the the
functionality the spiritual
functionality
of tazkia which is purification
so there's we don't have to have the
same name
with all due respect no we're not trying
to force
in fact and we're skipping obviously
here but
made it very clear when he was in charge
that jews were going to have the pension
they're going to have all the luxuries
that muslims have
the elderly jews were going to be
respected that they have their own
institutions that there will be a
pluralistic society
that they would have their own they
would have their own
laws being implemented in their
jurisdictions
this is more than what we have here as
muslims we don't have uh
courts that can islamic sharia courts
which actually have
implementation power these are just
fatawa that these mashayak give they're
not actually implementable
from a law perspective as for the quran
and islam it allows
the jews and the christians in
particular to have such jurisdiction
so these kinds of things which are held
against us
these monstrous falsehoods by people who
are intoxicated by false opinion
these things are actually contrary to
the facts
literally contrary to the facts look at
number six
the wrong party shall be aided doesn't
matter who they are yeah at the wrong
part it could be a muslim
against the jew and they shall be aided
the jew shall contribute to the cost of
all so long as they are fighting along
the believers medina shall remain sacred
and inviable
for all those who join in this treaty
should any disagreement arise between
the signatories to this treaty then the
allah that all high
and his messenger shall settle the
dispute and naturally as the head of the
state
and the chosen head of the state by
the the two major tribes who actually
had peace agreements with the jews
before that
the signatories to this treaty shall
boycott the quraish commercially
they shall also abstain from extending
any support to them it's extremely
important here
because the quraish was an antagonistic
and provocative political power now that
we're trying to
kill the muslims as we know with uh we
saw with brother we talked about bedouin
how the 313 but
this is a worrying country if you want
to have a civil society we can't have
agreements with the enemy tribes we
can't have that and those individuals
that tried to kill and boycotted the
muslims for 13 years
there have to be boundaries and those
boundaries must be respected
boundaries have to be respected
each shall contribute to defending
medina in the case of a foreign attack
in its respective area
and this treaty shall not hinder either
party from seeking lawful revenge
and you see this is in ibn hashem but
it's also
mentioned as i've mentioned and they've
been she had
book so it's there in the primary source
materials there clearly was
a um a treaty in place and when we talk
about
here what is connected to al-azab is
or the expedition and the killing of
those
treacherous and traitorous combatant
jewish tribe called banu quraida who
who were part of the azab these
individuals who are attacking
the the precincts of the holy area of
medina
because what happened was quraysh tried
to invade and this was a defense of war
for all intents and purposes
so much so that trenches it was called
khandak as well
literally they were which means trenches
they were they were
constructing trenches around the area
and the prophet muhammed the companions
were starving of hunger so much so
so much so that the prophet would even
tie a rock around his stomach
to get to trick the body into thinking
that it had food inside of it
this is the desperation that they let
this is the humanitarian crisis
that medina had been plunged into
because of the attacks
the constant and persistent violations
by the korushi's who attempted to invade
medina
so they built these trenches uh on the
city periphery and what happened was
this
you have three tribes of jewish tribes
you have been
there
and those three tribes had the same kind
of uh agreements with the prophet
muhammad
and what we what we find is that quite
frankly every single tribe
were aggressive to the prophet muhammed
in different ways
so we've mentioned probably the most
aggressive towards him
by teaming up with
the enemy and we're going to have a
segment on this in sapient thoughts
speaking about this incident by itself
but what they did effectively was that
they teamed up with the enemy in so much
as that they let them in
remember they'll be building trenches
around medina and so on but they let
them in
and the quran even has some verses
regarding this you know
if jaya ukum in focus
when they came and this is talking about
all the professors and executives say
this
when they came from in front of the city
and behind the city and
your eyes became uh and
you you couldn't maintain your vision
and when the hearts reach the throats
meaning you felt fair because
these guys were facilitating away and
opening up for women and children to be
slaughtered
opening up the city for women and
children to be slaughtered
the they're going against the agreements
they're going against the
pact they're going against the treaty
the constitution
and they are treacherous and trait
traitorous
this is clear treachery and then what
did the prophet do after all of this
and we'll go into this in more detail
the combatants among them
were killed and that how many of the
combatants
400 500 we don't know but were they
killed because they were jewish
if that was the case why is bernoulli
not killed
or killed in fact if it was about
jewishness why is the prophet even
getting married to a jew
he gets married to safe into haye after
that time
and she is jewish in ethnicity nothing
to do with anti-semitism this is all to
do with
these treaties and law and order
and we had strength at that time the
muslims and so we're not going to let
somebody be treacherous and try and kill
us
fool me once fool me once shame on you
for me twice shame on me
and that is why the prophet salallahu
hadith
which which spells out the political
realistic situation
he said in the hadith he said
the muslim is not bitten from the same
hole twice
meaning the thing that comes out the
whole we're not going to be tricked so
in other words we cannot
allow combatants in that area to do
those things
and so they were they were executed and
in clear surrender
because it was war that's what it was it
was war it wasn't a civil situation just
went into the village
as we're seeing now unfortunately unfold
in front of our eyes
bombing bombing civilians and so on
punishing children for the for the for
the actions
of other men that's how they punish
sorry you can't compare and talk about
massacres those same people that talk
about the massacre
are the supporters of israel and they're
supporters of them by the way
in their bombing and their shelling and
their disseminating
the gods and kids they just don't like
muslims they want to paint us in the
worst light possible
they don't want to admit that the
prophet muhammad had the most military
exceptional
skills as a strategist and in fact it
wasn't just a prophet muhammad let's be
honest
it was something that allah facilitated
so much so
that in this this particular war there
was a rock
and the prophet muhammed smashed it once
and he said allahu akbar and he says
hashem has been given
to me and he smashed it again and he
said the yemen has been given to me and
he smashed it again
and he said i think it was bahrain he
has been given to me so he
was gushing and he was making
predictions about the future in one of
the most
weakest moments one of the weakest
moments
in the whole time of the seerah he's
making predictions about the future
and obviously these predictions came out
to be true and as
barnaby rogerson says the similitude
of the the expansion that took place at
the time
i'm paraphrasing it there are at that
time with the arabian peninsula
where they took over the sassanid empire
and the persian and the roman empire
is like eskimos taking over russia and
america it's unbelievable thing that
happened in world history
when i was reading a book called a brief
history of
of the world by gumbridge when i got to
the chapter where it's talking about
prophet muhammed the expansion that
happened thereafter he was candid
even though he's an orientalist for
intents and purposes he said this is
probably the most amazing thing that i'm
going to write about in this whole book
and his remit was to write about all of
world's history
why because the truth of the matter is
that he had god on his side
these things cannot be replicated the
spread of christianity cannot be
linked to the all compared to the spread
of islam the spirit of
christianity was you had an empire an
emperor
who was constantine who became a
christian and he spread it by force
theodosius ii spread christianity by
force the
the the establishment was already there
the institution was already there all
that was required
was that the emperor changed his
religion and he enforced the laws
this was different this way you had a
bottom-up approach you had a man the
prophet muhammed who was accepted by the
tribes and then made his own polity
and built everything himself and then
islam expanded in a way
that nothing else can and ever will
expand in the in that way
and this in fact if these individuals
think this is evidence against islam
they are foolish because this is one of
the biggest evidences for the veracity
of islam
the fact that islam spread in this
manner after the prophet muhammad's
death by the way
but this azab and uh
that took place after it you cannot you
cannot say that this is because of
anti-semitism because these people were
jews
that is not the uh the attitude
that is not the attitude of the prophet
with the jews and
even to be honest with you fair-minded
orientalists and scholars not even
muslims will agree to this people like
karen
armstrong people like thomas arnold
walker
many people agree to that so here after
ahzaab and all those things took place
there's many different wars that took
place
and there's motta which took place as
well which was a war between the muslims
and the
the roman empire because there were
letters that were being sent out by the
prophet muhammed to different
emperors and he sent messengers and one
of them was to
the the people of the roman empire and
the assanis were there
uh in motta and basically what happened
was that
they killed the the ambassador you know
the diplomat the the emissary
they killed him and then the muslims
went and fought to revenge
that that thing so a lot of people think
that when the muslims went to the roman
empire
emperor empire and they fought them this
was because
they just wanted to expand no if you
look at what as a prime case study
they started the aggression there are
salads who are a um
a subcontracted group
who are connected to the roman empire
okay there were christian arabs on the
on the periphery of the roman empire
they indeed okay started the uh assault
and so the reactionary politic of the
prophet muhammad the strategy
that ensued sending a battalion to that
area
that was in reaction to
that particular event that took place
now i want to put something to you and
it's very important that we know
just as the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi sallam he knew how to go to war
he knew how to arrange an army he knew
how to do all of those things and
and he knew how to get make a civil
society
and to get all the tribes to come
together he also knew how to negotiate
and he also knew how to make peace and
he also knew how to make international
peace agreements
and this is of extreme importance for us
in this world that we live in now
because we are living in a post-world
war ii
society where we have the un and the
iamf and you have the world health
organization and these kind of
international agencies and organs
and the question is is an islamic state
capable of making peace treaties the
answer is yes
absolutely and i'll give you adebiya as
an example
and i'm going to read what the treaty of
said but just to give you a context
what happened was the prophet salallahu
salaam had a dream okay
and i'm i'm skipping a lot of the
battles that took place i've just told
you about better ahadep
but there are other battles and the
scholars say that the ones that the
prophet muhammad actually
kind of involved himself in were eight
some say nine in number
anyway the point is at one point the
prophet saw
had a dream and the dream was that
people were getting he was getting his
hair cut and trim some people getting
their hair can't people get their hair
trimmed
so it was interpreted that they were to
go to umrah the lesser pilgrimage
and on their way to umrah they were
confronted by this
nasty group of karashis that came
including
and others who basically tried to
prevent the prophet muhammed
he said look i'm not interested in
fighting we're just going to drama
to do pilgrimage and basically
they involved themselves in a
negotiation and
the negotiation was a negotiation for
peace and a fact
okay i'm gonna read out the terms of
this negotiation there are four major
terms i'm gonna read this out and this
is from the book
number one the muslims shall return this
time and come back next year so
basically they said look you can't come
tomorrow this year but you can come next
time
next year number two
what activities shall be suspended for
ten years during which both parties will
live in full security and neither will
raise swords against each other
this is of extreme importance because
one of the
poisonous and malignant and cancerous
and unfair i will say this to you unfair
criticisms of islam is that it's
incapable of creating peace
politically and that its only desire is
one of expansion and there's no
propensity for islam
to create peace and this second clause
here of the contract which by the way
obviously the prophet sallam agreed to
is a damning thorn in the neck of these
individuals who are promulgating such
narratives
he agreed to this that there will be a
peace treaty
the fact that the prophet saws agreed to
this and this was not abrogated
this was not abrogated that you can
still make peace means
to say means to say that any time now
any muslim government in history can
create peace or have peace agreements
with any non-muslim country that becomes
a possibility
and knowing that makes us realize that
islam
although labeling it as a religion of
peace as if that is the only remake of
islam
is not accurate but re but labeling it
as a religion of violence
and war is also not accurate the true
opinion is or the most balanced kind of
understanding is that has the propensity
for both
it has the propensity for both and this
clause ii here is an ample example of
that clause three
whoever by the way this is in bukhari
and so no one can say well sierra
literature no this is in bukhari
you can find this interaction between
the prophet muhammad in bukhari
number three whoever wishes to join
muhammad or enter into a treaty with him
should have the liberty to do so
likewise whoever wishes to join
or enter into treaty with them should be
allowed to do so number four anyone from
the quraysh
who goes over to muhammad salla with
obviously they don't right
i'm saying it myself without his
guardian's permission referring to a
fugitive shall be returned to quraysh
however if any of muhammad's followers
return to the quest he will not be sent
back
and they were tested with this because
there was one particular guy abu jandal
and he was a muslim that was with mecca
and abu jandal because of the terms of
agreement had to stay with the meccan
pagans even though
they were torturing him and stuff
because that is the level
that you have to stick with your
agreements and contracts let me tell you
this
as someone who has researched contracts
for a very long time
and not just research contracts and i'm
not talking about legalistic framework
in
british law i'm talking about the
islamic framework and comparing it with
a liberal
contractarian framework i will say this
to you
now and please remember this okay
the biggest point of intersection
and the biggest point of agreement and
the biggest point of
um similarity continuity
between the islamic tradition islamic
legal tradition
and the western liberal tradition
is contracts the quran
very candidly says oh you who believe
fulfill the contracts one of the signs
of a hypocrite
is a is if he fulfills a contract he
goes against it
one of the or conversely one of the
signs of a true believer
those who are to their trusts and their
contracts
people who take care of them in other
words
in other words contracts form the
bedrock of both
you could say the islamic legal system
and
the western liberal legal system they
are
extremely important and when you know
that then you start thinking about the
world and the politics and the
geopolitics in a different way
we can we can offer contracts of peace
of negotiation
we are capable of that as muslims
because not despite what the prophet
muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam did
but because of it and already you start
to realize the stark differences between
the prophetic mission
and groups uh uh outcast groups like
isis
they didn't believe in contracts in
negotiation candidly they did not
al qaeda does not believe in contracts
and negotiation why not
in the quran and the sunnah this is
something which is very explicit and
especially for weakened people
weakened people the prophet muhammad at
that time had a thousand five hundred
muslims
in the ten year period which which
didn't uh wasn't the whole ten years
that elapsed before this contract was
broken by the way the
people that became muslim through dawa
alone
it went up to almost ten thousand how do
we know that because
there was about ten thousand people
according to reports which from one
thousand five hundred to ten thousand is
a huge number
which shows you the importance of dawah
and the importance of promulgation to
islam
but the point is this is very important
that
we have the propensity and the ability
and the precedent and the legal
framework
as muslims traditionalists people who
stick to the quran sunnah
people who stick to the people who don't
want to deform
and to twist the religious edict we
still have the ability to what
we have the ability to create
contractual
agreements which are meaningful in islam
and in on the liberal framework that
also exists
that is to be fair that absolutely
exists
contractarianism and so this is
probably the biggest
breakthrough if you think about it in
the
context of world peace and how to
achieve it
it's very important dawa can
be can be the main way through which and
by which people convert to islam
people will receive the message of islam
now you don't necessarily it might not
it's not advantageous to act in a way
as we did in the medieval period
especially with american hegemony
so this gives us a framework of
acceptance
and it like i say it completely destroys
the narrative and i'll tell you
something else that destroys the
narrative
when the prophet muhammad sallallahu the
the clash of civilization narratives
the narrative that we're barbarians and
violent people only with the propensity
to be like that
another thing which destroys that
narrative is fatah conquest of mecca
and this is the test this is the litmus
test
some people they make a force comparison
they say look when we look at the new
testament
we see that jesus christ was a peaceful
character
jesus christ was a peaceful character
whereas the prophet muhammad he was a
man of war
and you see the difference between the
two well
actually jesus christ was always in a
situation of weakness
jesus christ according to the new
testament by the way is not
by the way that's false because we can
look at how jesus is portrayed
in the new testament and that's the
discussion of itself but the point is
you're comparing apples and oranges this
is this analogous
you don't compare jesus christ
with medina and muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam you compared jesus
christ with mecca muhammad allies
where they were both in the situation of
weakness and they were both under some
other kind of rulership
here now the question is how the how did
muhammad
sallallahu alaihi sallam react how did
he react when he went into mecca and he
done fat
conquest of mecca did he did he kill
everybody did he massacre and destroy
everybody
the way they would like us to believe
because they were different religion
or because they were because they were
against him because they killed him they
tried to kill him or they killed his
uncle
hind the woman who put washi
the man who killed his uncle hamza we
didn't speak about the conversion of
hamza we didn't speak about the
conversion of
but hamza was one of the most beloved
uncles to the prophet muhammad who was
killed in the battle of badr
who was killed in cold blood in the
battle of badr
and washi is the one who killed him but
after the conquest the prophet muhammad
he forgave
hind and he forgave washi the killer of
his own uncle
the forgiving prophet and he said let's
the same thing as what joseph said when
he saw his brothers
in the quran and also in the old
testament the story is there the point
being here is very clear
this fat point it puts a spanner in the
woodworks and it puts the cat in with
the pigeons
it completely disturbs the idea of a
power hungry
um malevolent individual that wants to
destroy everybody in this cold blood
because he did not
he forgave the people and he allowed
them to embrace islam
and those who didn't embrace islam they
were not killed
they were not killed there were
exceptions there were six exceptions of
those individuals who continued their
cantankerous and malignant
and cancerous warlike
warlike
promotion who were not who were not
forgived
forgiven but apart from them the people
were forgiven
and you see when he came into the kaaba
and he smashed
he destroyed the idols all 360 of them
that the arabs had become known
for and bilal the same one that the the
these arabs by the way they were racist
to him
they used to humiliate him they used to
be they actually were racist to him they
were attacking him
physically attacking him because he
believed in one god and put the boulder
on him he went up
and the arabs have an interesting saying
they say al jazeera
the recompenses from the same genus as
the action
and he went on top of the kaaba and when
he was
on top of the kaaba he he done the athan
he'd done the call to islamic prayer
he was honored they were talking about
obama
obama being the first black president
as if this is some kind of achievement
no sorry
obama he went to kenya and he was
telling them
to follow laws that would put and ideas
and ideologies
his own backyard that belonged to the
white man that guy
withhold you respect he he cannot be
compared to bilal and others that came
before him
and that he he was the leader of the
people he was there
on top of the kaaba literally above them
literally not just physically
not just figuratively doing their call
to prayer islamic prayer
married to an arab the prophet accepted
him
and then they they did exactly that they
broke the
the and this
you see now the farewell pilgrimage
and the prophet makes a final speech and
obviously
we're skipping a lot of things here
there were expeditions that took place
which we're not talking about because it
will descope and it'll make it too long
but the farewell pilgrimage of the
prophet muhammed
where he makes a speech and in that
speech he talks about racism
in that speech he talks about women's
rights in that speech he says that
there's no
superiority over a white man over a
black man or a black man over a white
man
yes or an arab over a non-arab or an
arab over an arab and that in the akron
the best of you are those who have
almost conscious
tell me now of a person in the 7th
century that was saying that kind of
thing
tell me now that you had winston
churchill the guy that was just in the
60s he was
you have you have a plethora you have a
catalogue of racist remarks that he
makes
don't don't compare your civilization
with ours
don't compare that he said that
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and he said be good
with women because they are prisoners
with you
telling us so look at this already
predating all of these movements that
took place and
saying the right thing at the right time
in the farewell speech of the prophet
muhammad sallallahu alaihi
and he outlawed interest
and he said all of it is modular all of
the ones that are
interest now is is is nullified
the exploitative practice that the whole
western economy is based on not only the
western economy
quite frankly the whole world economy he
he outlawed that
exploitative practice
and and just go on and go and see a
script
subhanallah of the farewell speech of
the prophet muhammad
how many things he told us to do
and it was called the farewell speech at
the front of my house for a reason
because this was the last speech he
would make in this kind of capacity
tens of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of people are listening to
this
can you imagine the scene can you
imagine a scene tens of thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of people listen
to this
and the ayat of the qur'an
islam came down the ayat which says that
they have perfected your religion
and we have completed your favor
and we have we have to allah
islam and we have made the religion of
islam as the pleasurable
religion we have we are we are uh for
you
so allah is pleased with islam as a
religion and in the same surah allah
says allah is
all of those walls that he took place in
allah would protect him so that he can
get to that
stage where he can say the final ayat of
the quran
and that is a miracle in and of itself
because had he died before these verses
came down the the verse would have been
disproven but this is another
proof of his miraculous prophethood
and after he did this the mission had
been done
and at one particular event you know to
show that the prophet muhammad was a
cosmopolitan man that was
with everybody he went to a jewish
woman's house and in fact he ate
something
and some of the scholars they say that
this thing she had put poison in it
and the companion that the prophet was
with ate more of it and he died the
prophet
sallam didn't eat as much of it to die
but then he fell ill
he was poisoned and by the way some
scholars say this is
makes him a shaheed because it's the one
who has been infected in their stomach
is one of the categories of
shaheed the mobtun and he was
subhanallah at the age of 62 63 he was
with his wife aisha
which we haven't spoken about and
wallahi we should have but she deserves
a lecture in and of herself
who was the you know the young wife
the inquisitive one she loved him she
loved aisha loved him
and he was just
with with with aisha and he was
basically like kind of leaning on her
you can imagine like you know he was
leaning on her
lap and he went to the toilet you know
felt sick felt oh and and at that time
he died
you know and you imagine this society
that he built and what he left behind
and this was the time where allah made
people come into islam in droves
in swades people were coming in
either
when you see the open manifest victory
of allah and the conquest
and you see people coming into islam in
droves so then
glory send glory to allah
and and be and it's your lord and and
because he is someone who accepts
repentance
and subhanallah ibn abbas who is the
cousin of the prophet muhammad
so the nephew of the prophet he said
this means that the prophet is going to
die soon
he knew what this meant and people were
getting upset and he did
indeed die sallallahu salaam
the people were shocked went into panic
mode
he took out his sword he said if anyone
says that he's dumb when i killed them
uh he said he had to come out and be and
you can see now he was the
leader the the mature the calm mind that
he came out he said whoever used to
worship muhammad
s
that certainly muhammad died and whoever
used to worship allah that allah is high
and he allah is ever living and he does
not die
and this was the life of the prophet
muhammad
after this spread islam in the most
amazing way
possible something which went in line
with the prediction of the prophet
muhammad as he said in the hadith of
east and western parts and my um my
nation
will reach all of that area what has
been projected from it
for me this is i've skipped a lot of
things here and i'm sure
uh people will you know notice that but
the point is i tried to make this an
hour and a half
for an introduction as an introduction
to the people to know who this great man
was
the brave muhammad sallallahu alaihi the
courageous the merciful muhammad
the family man the father muhammad the
man
who and we haven't gone into his
relationship with his children there's
lots of things that were missed out here
his relationship with his wives how he
was so
forbearing with them how he was so kind
with them
how he was a strategist politically and
militarily
but how also he was a family man and he
would prioritize them and how he would
he was a worshiper just the fact that
the man was praying
half the night on a regular basis or
more than half
the night as the quran mentions like he
was
a monk at night and a warrior by the
morning
how can how can a man do so much how can
a man do so much in such a little
small time frame
how can a man change the world so much
that we are talking about him now
as the quran says and we have raised
your mentioning
my name is muhammad and that is actually
a continuation also like fulfillment of
the fact that allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has
raised the station of allah it's one of
the most popular if not the most popular
name in the world
allah has raised the station of muhammad
allah and people are probably saying the
word muhammad now
any time in the world given time
someone's doing that then someone's
doing it
someone saying someone's calling
somebody most mentioned man in history
most mentioned man in history
most remembered man in history
and most influential man in history
muhammad sallallahu alaihi
if you didn't know now you know wasallam
alaykum
you